so shark week is uh celebrating all
things shark i don't really know i've
never seen it but i i understand from
the channels i pay attention to the this
piece of video emerged on shark weekend
caused a certain amount of uh okay so i
have not seen the video in question
you're only gonna have this there's no
sound being there's no sound so we can
talk right over it and you don't really
okay need the sound
now we have here
is a shark
that's oh that is a shark yeah
and he's maneuvering around using his
pectoral fins and at one point here he
actually kind of goes over
a little berry shark uh no that is not a
shark
um but anyway we're back okay we've got
very shallow uh presumably salt water
here like an intertidal zone almost
maybe yeah um
with a shark
right little little leopard-spotted
shark cute little guy um using his bread
said his pictorial fins to
um gosh propel himself over very
in very very shallow water now can we
agree and or his i mean his gills are
still underwater right yeah well they're
moist i think the gills go out of water
here briefly yeah and then he maneuvers
into the next little pool now the claim
here is that this is the first time this
has been seen who said that you see the
discovery count of shark week tonight
shark week yeah uh is it the first time
it's been seen yeah not by the sharks
presumably
ah well that's the question this is like
cristobal cologne discovering america
right that's the first time sharks have
done this no
so right
snowball cologne who discovered a pair
of continents with something like 50
million people living very well there
the sharks
have presumably been trying this out
this is i never know about the time i
discovered manhattan
how much did you pay for it
uh too much and i didn't even get to
keep it but yeah um
yeah i mean
is it possible that uh some videographer
witnessed the very first time that is
shark now i mean it's impossible but
but even the claim that this is the
first time it's been observed i find
very unlikely for
reasons i want to briefly explore okay
so observed by people is the idea yeah
okay um so
uh
in evolutionary biology we sometimes use
the metaphor of the adaptive landscape
in which opportunities are pictured as
peaks and obstacles of moving from one
opportunity to the next are valleys
now the reason that this is useful
as a metaphor is that it highlights
certain counter-intuitive things about
what actually uh drives and impedes
evolution
or adaptive evolution at least
which is to say
the depth of a valley
dictates the likelihood of a creature
evolving from one opportunity to a
better opportunity not the difference in
height between the two opportunities
there can be some very good way of being
that's pretty near where you are but if
the obstacle and the evolutionary
obstacle to getting there is
particularly deep
particularly deep
you're unlikely to jump that gap
now the opposite is also true we don't
talk about this as much
but opportunities where there is no gap
where what there is a gentle slope where
if you evolve in this direction things
just simply start getting better and
keep getting better for some
long period those are almost certain to
be crossed
and so
my point would be this exact adaptation
is known from
i've got at least four examples in mind
different clades that have done it
all right we've got coelacamps we got
lungfish we got mud skippers
and i forgot mine before coelacanths and
lungfish could
plausibly be the same uh the same event
given that they are sort of they're both
near the base of the um the
cerakopterygian tree uh and we tetrapods
uh are the other big group and since
we're out of water who knows you know
it's possible that sort of at the base
of the sarcopte the lopefin fish tree
uh you had this ability and both
lungfish and coelacanths inherited that
ability from their most recent common
ancestors possible i think and it's been
many years since i looked at it but i
think it's more likely to be a
parallelism where those two clades both
had the characteristics that made this
likely to evolve yeah and it's been a
while since i've taught a vertebrate
evolution so i haven't looked but as i
remember it these sort of you know
coelacanths lungfish
tetrapods group um the resolution
between those three clades isn't uh
isn't totally clear i don't think we
know for sure who's most basal within
that group
it's a scaly question at the very least
yeah sorry but
anyway
the point is so wait you had mud
skippers seal counts lungfish you have
another one i've forgotten what it is i
had one okay so mudskippers being
actinops act ray-finned fish
uh you know solidly would then basically
name a fish it's probably an
ecknopterygian okay sharks sharks aren't
telecats aren't lung fish aren't um but
almost every sturgeon
sturgeon are acting not regions but not
teleos anyway it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter but
point is look
there are lots of circumstances in which
something that we would call a fish fish
by common parlance
faces a situation in which either
it's trapped with a danger that it could
survive if it can get out of the
body of water that has the danger and
into a body of water that doesn't
or more often there's some opportunity
there's a puddle that contains prey over
there but i'm over here and there's a
little bit of somewhat dry land between
here and there and if i could only just
you know wiggle my way across that piece
of land there are lots and lots of
circumstances in which it's useful to be
able to do a little bit of locomotion on
land and they happen to be armed
with pectoral fins
terrible
not pretty good actually but
but anyway lots of circumstances in
which it would be useful to be able to
do that the mode of locomotion actually
leads directly to this discovery in
other words the wiggling
motion of a fish in swimming also puts
the pectoral fins you know alternately
on the substrate and so
my point is
this is one of these things that is
probably unknown because we haven't
looked for it not because it's uncommon
yes and this is there's another one of
these they're not just going to lay
there and die
they're going to do everything they can
to get out of a situation if suddenly
they find themselves in shallow water
right it's bound to got lateral
undulation and they've got pictorial
fins and you know put them together and
do what you can
right and the number of individuals who
were birthed to some creature who
succeeded at this and therefore didn't
starve is liable to be large and so the
question really is a
how common is this behavior in clades
where we haven't seen it my guess is
it's a lot more common than we think
yeah um
b any kind of like you know fish um
probably not like a deep body form fish
but you know any kind of fish that tends
to be in intertidal zones you know with
tide pools that sometimes will dry up
more than they were expecting
yeah tide pools that dry up or tide
pools where an unusual tide will make a
puddle wet and an animal will get
trapped and it has to get out because
that pool isn't going to be wet again
for another month or something yeah and
just so deep body form just refers to
sort of a
like an angel fish imagine an angelfish
or a sunfish one of these fish that's
basically like a disk on the side where
you know no matter how hard they try
they try to use their well a their
pectoral fins tend to be
tend to be up on the body so they
probably wouldn't even reach but they'd
also just tip over yeah so you need to
have a somewhat flattened form for this
for this to work yeah
but anyway the number of circumstances
is huge it's not likely to happen for
anything in deep bodies of water um but
there are a lot of animals that have a
niche that puts them in proximity with
idiosyncratic shorelines this is not the
other bound to be bound to be somewhat
common and
also highly likely this is one of these
questions where
if you were to survey the indigenous
people of all of the coastlines of the
world my guess is you'd come up with a
bunch of them that had seen this
behavior of course sharks do that right
of course sharks do that yeah and that
this is new to science which i don't
even know if it is new to science but if
it's new to science it's really cool if
it's not new to science it's still
really cool well i mean one of the
things you're saying maybe the least
interesting one but you know
if it's new if it's not due to science
discovery channel will hear about it
if it's not new to humanity
but it is new to science uh the claim
stands right right um and you know this
this is the kind of thing that the the
dei folks claim to be caring about right
like don't don't imagine that you with
your wonderful
wizarding scientific ways can come in
and and see things that actually other
people have been observing for a while
and claim it as your own
well okay let's let's imagine that if
you know given given what this
particular thing is
it almost certainly has been seen by
other human beings
but that doesn't mean that those other
human beings inherently
had the
you know the the
i used the term wizarding but you know
the scientific abilities to consider
what it means or under what
circumstances it would evolve or when it
might happen when it might happen they
might have the skills to have deduced
that if it had um practical application
for them you know if if the sharks are
good eating and there is a way to uh
predict when they might go kind of
pseudo-terrestrial and thus get them to
go into something where they'll be
easier to catch well you can be pretty
sure that where those sharks exist there
are going to be people who have a good
sense of how it is that they locomotive
or land when they do yep and i must tell
you in this case um
had we been somewhere in the field and
observed this
i would definitely have thought it was
hugely cool and i would remember it for
the rest of my life and i would have
certainly discussed it
i don't know that i would have even
thought that what i was looking at was
new to science and therefore i needed a
report and you know there is a mechanism
it gets done i think less these days but
um
there used to be natural history notes
or important features of behavior that
had never been observed before or never
been recorded in scientific literature
before could be reported without you
needing to have a you know data
justification just i saw this animal do
that thing which says no i published one
of these about about my frogs
it was like some little piece of
you know
observed predation right uh attempted
predation on these poison frogs in
madagascar where like okay enough people
enough people are just interested but
also enough people are thinking about
both the boas and the zonosaurs which
are these lizards and these frogs and
the toxins and the fogs there's a lot of
ways in that you might really want to
know if anyone has ever observed either
successful or attempted predation on
these frogs and you know i happen to see
two and i don't know the fate of the
zonosaur and i do know the fate of the
boa which is that uh the boa took this
frog into its mouth
gently chewed on it for 10 minutes
finally released the frog frog went on
to be fine
went on to become a mother who fed her
kids and the boa um moved dens shortly
thereafter and i think was fine although
i'm not actually totally sure because i
didn't see it after a couple weeks but
anyway natural history notes where
there's no there's no
experiment of hypothesis or experiment
or you know rigorous data collection
it's hey i was in the field and i saw
this
and this might this is interesting maybe
it's just interesting but it might also
be useful to other people well i mean
i think there is a way
in which it fits exactly the um
falsificationist ethos of science
in the following sense
anything that you have seen happen once
happens absolutely and so if we assume
that the hypothesis is that that
behavior does not exist until evidence
accumulates that it does how much
evidence do you need one honest report
of having seen it is enough to say that
it is at least within the realm of
things that happen that's exactly right
and also there's always a problem for
animal behaviorists
uh in that in order to do careful
rigorous work uh we need to you know
spend hundreds thousands of hours in the
field taking careful notes by you know
whatever means that we have established
in advance
um but the really coolest stuff may
still be out of our views you know the
more socially complex the organisms are
that we're watching the more likely
they're going to hide from us and not
you know do the the interesting stuff
where we can see it and it's just also
just very likely to be rare and so one
event
you cannot run statistics on but it
still does is worthy of discussion and
of publication and of um figuring out
what else must be true if you know if if
that thing happens if for instance
the you know what she called i think
aptly war
that jane goodall observed between the
two troops of uh chimps at gambi which
you know there's objection to the term
but uh never again did she see anything
exactly like that and thank god that she
didn't was like well i can't report that
because i just saw it once like no you
report when the chimps engage in war
you've totally reported that that's a
great example
um yeah i would point out actually
there's one of these uh for me where i
have not published a note but probably
should have
when i was working on tent making bats
there was a
uh a survey article that compiled a
review article that compiled all of the
information on tent making bats and it
you know had useful tables in it where
it took all of the species or 16 species
that are known to engage in the behavior
and described what sorts of plants they
used and the architectures and all
but the problem is
i became quickly convinced
that the
species
that was most commonly observed to be a
tent maker never makes tense at all that
it's a tent thief is this aj yeah
artibius jimmy census and the thing that
first clued me into that was it was the
only one that used all of the
architectures that were known from that
location
right but so you have to understand
nobody had seen a bat make a tent so the
inference that they made you were the
first person ever to either see yeah
well in this case you
so i mean how are we not in a little bit
of the same situation do you are you
certain
how certain are you that no native
peoples had ever observed a bat naked
tent
pretty sure
well it's a lot more subtle and cryptic
here here's the reason for a number of
reasons then here's the reason
yeah yeah but there's also a technical
reason okay um
bats are very shy about
uh making tents so they kind of don't do
it when you're standing there yeah
um
they
do it under cover of darkness yeah
and enter a cover of the leaves that
they are modifying to make into the
tents right so the point is these are
happening low in the understory of a
forest that absorbs 99 of the light that
hits it before it gets the floor so the
dark floor in the night
and they are very sensitive about people
so what i was able to do to observe this
was i knew enough about the tense and
the behavior to spot one that had just
begun
and i set up infrared this is before
infrared cameras were i mean the cameras
were available but there wasn't night
shot on
video cameras that you could buy so i
made an illuminator out of leds from uh
from basically uh remote controls for
tvs
i built them into a lucite block right
150. no it was the bad bright 4 000.
i knew 150 was low i i kept making ones
that didn't have enough power and i kept
increasing the power the that 4000 is
the one that really revolutionized the
industry
me being the industry
um but anyway i i built this thing and
it was powered off at 12 volt batteries
which i hauled into the forest and
hauled out during the day and charged
them and i set up these uh infrared
cameras basically just bank surveillance
cameras which are sensitive in the
infrared
and i was able to put that under the
leaf that was being modified and i could
sit you know 50 meters away where i
wasn't disturbing the animal and just
quietly sit there and watch the thing
happen so the point is the conditions
would it a
if i hadn't had the tech i wouldn't have
been able to see anything
if i'd stood there without light it
wouldn't work if i'd stood there at all
it probably would have dissuaded the
animal from building so in that case yep
probably on the other hand
some of the species do build these
things in
urban areas so it's possible that you
know in a in a village somewhere
bats building in a palm high up and uh
above the ground who might not have been
as disturbed
could have done it
but anyway to go back to the arctivious
thing
before you continue so uh aj artibius
jamie census is uh described
uh
with a particularly uh sort of juicy
detail bites ferociously when handled
yes which it does yes um yeah it's a
very this is the field notes for how to
identify what battery you're holding
bites ferociously when handled ah
that'll be the one then yeah okay so
it's larger than the other tent makers
which is still like you know body size
is still very small i mean wingspan
yeah wingspan would be six eight inches
um the uh
but so it's it's like the size of a fist
the animal's body it's a pretty large
animal and it's much so the thing is the
tent makers are all small this one's
conspicuously large and it doesn't stick
with a tent style
all of which made me strand step makers
well
it began it made me suspect something
was not right about this bat and then i
started to test that hypothesis
by looking at the data that other people
had taken on tents and the point was
there was no case in which this animal
had ever built a tent
had ever been observed to inhabit a tent
that was not also the species of plant
and the architecture of tent built by
some other animal in the same location
that was sympatric yep right so that
is a uh
is
strongly suggestive evidence then the
natural history observation is the
observation that a tent that i knew was
inhabited by another species was taken
over by artibius jimmy census proving
it's a thief
right so the point is that kind of
information
it doesn't prove it's only a thief but
um the circumstantial plus plus that
suggests that
and the fact that he doesn't look like
any other ten majors right so all of
those things combine but the the point
is the one thing there that is um
more than just suggestive is the fact
that it is known at least in one case to
inhabit tents that were previously
inhabited by a different species so
anyway that's worthy of a note because
it means that anybody later on studying
these animals can at least say
well i'm starting from the knowledge
that sometimes artibia's jimmy census
does take over a tent from another
species yeah no it's it's a it's a it's
a first step it's a foundation on which
another research program could be built
and it's worthy of being shared this is
you know this is what
the scientific record is supposed to be
doing for us and instead it's
increasingly being filled with
garbagey claims about people wanting an
alienating work environment as evidenced
by those who are making those claims
actually creating a
alienating environment for everyone yes
exactly yeah feeling good about
themselves for doing something no i
don't know we can't
maybe
or just feeling like they're secure in
their jobs now that they have stood up
for the currently fashionable thing and
that's not what scientists are supposed
to be doing i'm supposed to be standing
up for the currently fashionable thing
[Music]